how's it going brothers welcome to Star
Wars Battlefront we so you're a big star
Wars fan hey you good well we're gonna
play against each other
mm-hmm and dad I think someone's gonna
get their ass kicked
so uh thing about this Star Wars
Battlefront is that it's authentic to
the Star Wars universe so everything you
see will look like the movies so in this
game you can play online or you can play
missions where we play against each
other which one do you want to do
mission so there will be swarms of
enemies and we will have to survive as
long as we get Admiral Ackbar
I think that's his name and there's a
mean okay I'm sorry
if you want to do his voice just like
smile while you talk with your under lip
like this are the croc souls in this
game if you one of your friends whose
high rank you can play us the same and
you play together you can play as the
same ranks yes you see you mm-hmm
come on you honey sure wait wait I hear
I hear it where is it oh my gosh yeah
what are you doing have no matter no jet
pack away from him damn it I spent
almost
jet packs format yeah yee-gurr-gahh
okay we're gonna do battle against each
other which one do you want to do oh
that's cool
what is la yes oh I get to please him or
dark all right the pen thing you're a
fan said hesitance head Yayoi damp out
the dockside I don't know what I can do
I didn't know I oh we're in Endor what
do you having what are you eight oh yeah
yeah
now your friends say [ __ ] me come
back in ten ah damn it it's very limited
this power actually yeah I see you
around for shooting Oh God
you know you do a guy pushed me out in
public how are you doing where are you
going how did you get that shield up I
want to she'll wait wait am I the Red
Bull
now calm down are you winning am I not
no you're not let me just clarify that
you're absolutely not winning feel that
wow yeah yeah which one do you want the
monkey where's the monkey
actually is that you call where you call
that a monkey it's a okay so I can be
Luke Han or Princess Leia obviously I'm
gonna be on so it's funny cuz Han means
I can oh god he looks weird
oh is Han versus there but you think
they're meeting oh my god there's a fine
Vader pop pop pop pop pop pop hey don't
throw swords at me crazy I can do it you
can choke me I'll choke you yeah you
missed your toe you're gonna choke then
be a broker what you want dark plate and
what you wanna shoot you and you balls
and you roll my balls
no light your character ezel peep what
the game looks so pretty where are they
it's same man and your frostbite engine
Swedish people made this dies your
advance for you doing over there bud dad
get him are you kidding me what are you
doing right okay are you kidding me
seriously yeah this is for the princes
man you got to do this for that princess
mine stop Padma
stop what happened what happened
ah Jesus right in my ear okay one one
less all-or-nothing whoever wins has to
get a butt tattoo okay I will play as a
look please be nice Wobbuffet he's one
of my favorite characters okay what
about Gemma huh
Jabba you won't be jealous I'll be layer
then I'm look uh hey where are you going
I'm gonna kill you if you're a freaking
jet pack that's not fair man okay we do
one final and if you win we will get
french blood
hurry really yes really really really
I'm legit nervous not because I
genuinely don't want to buy a French
bullet is that happen if I went I have
to be you although can I be that afraid
they're here I think you should be
barfed on this map because this is like
his level
I'm so [ __ ] suck this struggle
Israel this is way to attend you put the
space way too high look at that guy what
is he doing what a legend Tim that shoes
too bad so yeah that was sours bound
front really awesome game really fun to
play just with your friends oh I just
friends this yeah or play online if
you're a fan of Star Wars you should
definitely check this out
thanks to EA for help making this video
remember to check out the game if you're
interested it's in the description and
that's all for now
leave a like if you enjoy space and I
will see you in the next one no French
Bulldogs know that's a passion it's not
a come on I do are you doing stop